[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up Prof hello Martin hello
Walter how are you doing well in human
are you doing fine I'm always fine are
you the same as yesterday or the day
before
the past three years oh okay
let's open with a word of prayer it
doesn't look as like you're always fine
I think you should Thou shalt not bring
a false testimony here
okay I don't know what to say about but
you're mostly fine I'm mostly fine
excellent
our heavenly father
we can always be fine when we bring
everything to you so we ask that you
please enlighten our minds with the
discussion again
and bless the viewers and Us in Jesus
name amen amen
and I would have privilege it is to be
able to do these things oh definitely
God is good huh I opens doors closes
doors
sometimes you think you must go over
there and you find out no you actually
have to be over there Paul had the same
thing right
he went there and the doors closed it
goes there the doors closed it goes
there and he thinks he must go there and
he must go to another place
he thinks he's going to this place or
that place he ends up in Rome it's all
very confusing
yeah and it can be um
overwhelming sometimes
because you you've planned and you've
set your mind okay we have to do this
and then all of a sudden no this is not
the way so I think a lot of people can
maybe sometimes get overwhelmed and say
oh okay so I give up
but the Lord gives you strength and he
when you walk in line with what he wants
you'll show you the right way now what
if you have
over a hundreds
lectures or whatsapps or whatever
which one do you give which one do you
pass on
you can't ask that question because let
God do it
he knows what everyone wants and he'll
make sure that that individual gets what
what he needs what he requires
so people always ask which one should I
give
pray about it I don't know exactly what
does that person need one needs one
thing then another one needs another
but uh the more there is the more
options there are available that's true
so we have to talk about tsunamis
plagues Tree of Life
so modern run us through what is this
all about well it's just again some
questions and out of questions there
sometimes comes a nice Bible study
so we look at a few it sounds very
um
scattered if you look at the titles
but eventually all these things come
back together
and it links in with prophecy so that's
why it's always nice to
to build the puzzle to see what's going
on
well let's see what tsunamis seven last
plagues and the tree of life is all
about
wouldn't the Fallen Angels eventually
die on their own since they no longer
have access to the Tree of Life
revelation 22 verse 2.
revelation 22 verse 2 reads in the midst
of the street of it and on either side
of the river
was there the Tree of Life which beared
12 manner of fruits and yielded their
fruit every month and the leaves of the
tree were for the healing of the Nations
in verse say
now nowhere in the Bible do we read that
Angels partake of the tree of life no
so whether they do or whether they don't
it is not revealed and there's a little
rule which says do not go beyond what is
written
but what is written is that life is
conditional
true and that must apply to everybody
including the Angels life is conditional
conditional to being subject to the
order and government of God because that
is based on love yeah
and if you do not want to be part of
that system
then you exclude Yourself by your own
choice
that's the main point everybody's got
free choice yes including the Angels now
let's look at this a little bit
the fall of Satan Satan was once an
honored angel in heaven next to Christ
his countenance like those of the other
Angels was mild
and expressive of Happiness his forehead
was high and Broad showing great
intelligence
his form was perfect he's bearing Noble
and Majestic but
when God said to his son let us make man
in our image Satan was jealous of Jesus
he wished to be consulted concerning the
formation of man and because he was not
he was filled with Envy
jealousy
and hatred he desired to receive the
highest honors in heaven next to God
now these three things Martin Envy
jealousy
and hatred they are progressive
nice you start with the one
you proceed to the next one
you end up with an with the last one and
hatred is murder yeah
yeah that's true
if you hate your brother it's as good as
committing no no that's what the Bible
says so you end up being an adversary
that wants to kill
it's a rather sad progression
and what was he before
he was happy
it was mild
and he was Noble he was Majestic
where's he now
degraded
degraded he's right to the lowest pits
of hell
so if this
Envy jealousy and hatred did it to Satan
how much more not to us absolutely now
will they not die on their own accord
well who sustains life who's the author
of life God is
God so where do angels derive their life
from from him where do we derive our
life from same place so everybody gets
life from the same source
imagine being jealous of the one who
gives you life
and you it reaches the point where you
want to kill the one that gives you life
is that seems rather
secular reasoning illogical right it's
as good as you say I'm mad at oxygen so
I don't want to breathe anymore
that's a very good analogy
so if you were envious of oxygen and
became jealous and wanted to destroy it
it would actually destroy yourself
so actually it it's a sign of stupidity
now what makes you so stupid
Envy Envy Envy makes you stupid
and envy makes you jealous
and then you're self-destruct that's
what happens right
all right so Angels derived their life
from the life-giver
and Jesus said he has life within
himself
do you have life within yourself no well
you have life but it's derived yes it's
given to you
and when that life is taken back
then you return to dust and then you are
no more yeah
although some in the religious World
want to say no you continue in another
form no life is gone
it's gone it has to be given back and
when will that happen
and the second coming at the
resurrection yes and I've been reading
the the gospels again and the writings
of Paul
it's so clear
every time it says at the last day yeah
at the last day
at the last day and I've been been
looking at the recurrence of this phrase
as it appears in every single epistle
and people read right over it
no at your death no at your death no at
your death no at your death
the Bible doesn't say that no at the
last day the last day anyway so when
Angels get their life from God
then is God able to take it back again
yes
okay
so why is he sustaining the devil
to let the great controversy play itself
out ah
to prove to the world
that if you give this system
that Satan envisioned enough rope it
will eventually hang itself
how long did it take the unfallen angels
to lose all sympathy
with the Devil
4 000 years
fall up to the cross up to the Cross
that's when the last sympathy
disappeared
I saw Satan fall like lightning from
Heaven hadn't he Fallen already yes but
not not in sympathy yes did he still
have access yes he did have access to
the to Heaven still until when until the
cross until the cross Martin you've been
reading I'm proud of you
until the cross he had access
and until the cross
he could try to manipulate Minds even
the minds of the angels and he was the
accuser of men
before God yes he continually came in
there and was accusing and then God
and the cross said and when he had an
opportunity
he would try to
reason with the angels right
and some of them were
does he have a point I don't think he
has a point but you know it's bothersome
all sympathy
vanished at the cross
but Satan wasn't eliminated at the cross
he was vanquished it was a beaten foe
but he did not
lose his life no he continued because
the great controversy hadn't played
itself out
so they received life from God
and when God removes that life from him
fire will proceed out of him and devour
him and
reduce him to ashes yeah and that will
be from within from within because
that's where sin started
I was sown this comes from early writing
Satan as he once was a happy exalted
Angel then I was sown him as he now is
he still Bears a kingly form his
features are still Noble for he is an
angel Fallen
but the expression of his countenance is
full of anxiety care
unhappiness malice hate Mischief deceit
and every evil
now those are spiritual aspects right
and also if I if you read it like that
it's also actually Progressive yes you
start with anxiety care and happiness
then it turns over into malice right
mischief and deceit
and that brow that was once so Noble I
particularly noticed his forehead
commenced from his eyes to recede
now Martin that's a physical aspect so
is there a physical digression yes
definitely all right so he's going
backwards
I saw that he had so long bent himself
to evil that every good quality was
debased and every tray
was developed his eyes were cunning sly
showed great penetration
his frame was large but the flesh hung
Loosely about his hands and face is that
a degradation and physical yeah physical
as I beheld him his chin was resting
upon his left hand he appeared to be in
deep thought the smile was upon his
countenance which made me tremble
it was so full of evil and satanic
slyness the smile is the one he wears
just before he makes sure of his victim
and as he fastens the victim and his
snare his smile grows horrible
all right so there we have a physical
description
so Martin he is on the way
to becoming
like Fallen Humanity but since God
sustains him he still has a far more
noble appearance than the human form
as we said before
man resembled the Angels until the time
of Abraham
and then there was a rapid decline
and now we look like shrimps
and everything else does too right
so when we hold an apple in our hand
then Adam would hold it like this and
say what is this a berry
so everything is in Decline so
God sustains him
and God keeps him going until the great
controversy is ended
and that will be for another Thousand
Years
plus an infinitesimal number
beyond that
and then he will be ultimately destroyed
and so that's also where the other
Angels come in the Fallen ones like God
is still sustaining them
for that day
now some of them are of course more
degraded than others
uh I it's just like Humanity we have the
whole Spectrum
there are still people around that have
a noble bearing
and there are people around that have
zero bearing
and in between you have the whole gamut
and the the same will be the case in the
case of the Angels some of them are so
so degraded and so Fallen
that they probably work with the rock
stars
Maybe not maybe the more intelligent
ones work with the rock stars yeah
the others work with the
with the rest of humanity
so to what extent is the statement in
Jeremiah 5 22 true in the case of a
tsunami
well Jeremiah says fear ye not says the
Lord will ye not trample at my presence
which have placed the sand for the bound
of the Sea by a Perpetual decree
that it cannot pass it though the waves
thereof toss themselves
yet can they not Prevail though they're
Raw yet can they not pass over it
okay
where when God created the world and he
created the beautiful Seas there wasn't
an ocean as we have it today
but he created the beautiful season
everything that is around it
did he put a boundary to those beautiful
seas that they shouldn't pass over yes
uh did he overturn that boundary at some
stage yes
completely yeah completely did it
destroy everything it was a climatic
catastrophe okay climate change did he
release the the waters that were above
the firmament
did he release the waters that were
below the firmament were they supposed
to be bound there yeah so can God
unbind them yes well if you combine them
then you can unbind them right
can he permit them to be Unbound
definitely
all right does it state that nature will
be turned on its head yes and you see
this really puts the people that say God
is bound by nature's laws it's above
nature is that it's outside of nice
family
a very good point
all right so this is describing the
normal situation it doesn't describe the
abnormal situation
because you would have to apply it to
everything you would have to apply it to
the wind
does it sometimes Roar and cross its
boundaries of what is seems right yes
when hurricanes come and destroy
everything including human life
so were they supposed to do that in the
beginning no
what about erosion Martin does erosion
take place today yes degration in every
form so what causes erosion
well boundaries getting pushed over that
weren't supposed to be bushed over so it
can be wind erosion can be water erosion
the most common form to wash everything
away is water so you have massive
rainstorms
were there rain storms in the beginning
no there was no rain
so that means
erosion was limited right
now if everything is covered in a
verdura of green
then if you have no rain will you have
erosion no
no so we're living in a fallen world
where everything is not covered in green
and some areas are open to erosion more
than others
and even where they are covered in green
you have high mountain slopes and ragged
ridges where water rushes down did that
exist in the beginning no
isn't there a quote in the spirit of
Prophecy that says that the cliffs and
the rocks are like the skeleton of the
earth that's showing After the flood
yes it's been totally reorganized torn
apart turned upside down
all of these things so Martin if you
have a heavy period of erosion
that does the the boundary of the sea
then change yes yes
can move in inward or outward depending
on the situation so those are situations
that you have in a fallen world when you
have an earthquake
and that creates a tsunami
a tsunami will cross the boundary
but were there earthquakes in the
anti-diluvian perfect world before it
was before sin came into the world no no
it was absolutely stable actually for
that first thousand years it was stable
till the flood with Noah yes there must
have been catastrophes already that were
taking place after the fall because
there were changes there must have been
uh desification because thorns and
thistles started appearing but the
changes weren't as dramatic
so we can look at this verse and say yes
God put the boundaries but God can
permit the boundaries to be
overstepped definitely
in job we read then Satan answered the
Lord and said does job fear God for
naught
Hast not Thou made a hedge about him
about his house and about all that he
has on every side that has blessed the
work of his hands and his substance is
increased in the land
but put forth thine hand now and touch
all that he has
and he will curse thee to thy face
and the Lord said unto Satan behold all
that he has is in thy power only upon
himself put not forth thine hand
so Satan went forth from the presence of
the Lord and behold there came a great
wind from the Wilderness and smote the
four corners of the house and it fell
upon the young men
and they are dead and I only am escaped
alone to tell thee that's Job 1 19.
who actually brought the storm
Satan who permitted it God
there's a lesson in that right we often
often complain Where's God in all of
this if God permitted it
and does it sometimes happen that uh
people that you would expect would not
be hit by these calamities are actually
hit by the calamities
all of the time fortunately your family
is always without calamities and mine
too we never suffer Calamity since we
discovered the way of life calamities
have ceased completely
is that true uh are you allowed to bear
false witness I'm asking a question
no
and where do I find comfort
in the Book of Job that's it
that's why the Book of Job is included
so that in case we lose hope we can read
about the story of Job how differently
especially when you
when you have the Viewpoint that because
you're a child of God you will put you
in a box and let you not be part of any
of this in the world in this world you
will have tribulation but you have good
chair
I have overcome the world
now when I read
through the gospels again and through
the writings of Paul
and you read about the experiences and
you read about what happened to them in
the book of Acts
isn't that the story of Job to the power
of 10 to the power of a hundred yeah
if the world if if you were of the world
the world would love you yeah
yeah but seeing that you are not of the
world the world will hate hey and they
will persecute you
and they will they will rub your nose in
the ground and if they possibly can
they'll throw it in the fire live and
put you on the rack and do whatever did
they do it oh yes
many times where was God when his
Martyrs were on the rack right there
next to them right there next to them
right they were crucifying Christ afresh
and just like those that crucified him
literally
we'll have a special Resurrection at the
second coming so many of these
persecutors will have a special
Resurrection
they will have the privilege to die
three times
yes Dave
I would not want to be an Inquisitor
who ran the Inquisition by the way
actually the church
the church the Dominicans and the
Jesuits
I would tremble to join a Jesuit order
would you not definitely but but let's
not go there they'll say that we no no
but there's another thing that came to
mind now
that was the Middle Ages we're going
back to a time where there is going to
be an inquisition Martin I think the
Middle Ages have been surpassed
the tools are different they are more
subtle
but they are more destructive yeah I
think more people are being destroyed
and murdered and driven to Despair and
suicide today by the very actions of
these people just take a look at Jesuit
theater let's call it Hollywood which is
witchcraft
how many people have committed suicide
because of implanted ideologies yeah
uncountable uncountable the Middle Ages
pales into insignificance when you look
at the evil that is perpetrated by these
Monsters of modern day and if you take
it it's not only going to be the Roman
Catholic Church no no it does the
persecution
how many people died at the hands of
persecutors even amongst the reformed
churches right
well Martin
the fact of the matter is we are not
living in in Utopia
we are living in a world that is doomed
and that is heading towards destruction
but be of good cheer yeah
for he has overcome the world and with
him and together with him and in him we
can overcome too
so what is our job
to look at the world and to bemoan its
state
or to try and seek and save the lost
that's that is what your main point
should be because the other one will
discourage you completely yes
so what is the greatest joy
that anybody can
attain to
have the everlasting life through Jesus
Christ in other words when you can lead
someone to Jesus Christ and give them
hope and a life
in a world that is as destroyed as this
one
that is the greatest joy how long will
that Joy last forever
it'll last forever cannot beat that
isn't that amazing
and if you think of people that have
children God entrust the children to
them
the greatest the greatest challenge is
to bring them to eternal life because
that will last forever
and the devil makes it very difficult
sometimes and there are the young men
jobs children
and they died
and how did they die what were they
doing
when they died feasting they were
partying
a bit uh concerning her
but then he had those beautiful
daughters
that's scary to have a beautiful
daughter is scary too because that means
the wolves are there as well
but I'm sure that God will give him
trophies definitely and he will have
trophies in heaven yet also very nice
friends
yes miserable comforters
foreign
Works through the elements also to
Garner his Harvest of unprepared Souls
he has studied the secrets of the
Laboratories of Nature and he uses all
of his power to control the elements as
far as God allows and to bring about
so-called climate change Martin you
shall not go beyond what is written
it doesn't stand there no you are
interpolating here all right let's stop
where where he really stops he uses all
his power
to control the elements as far as God
allows all right let me ask the question
then is God allowing more and more
yes because the Four Winds that the
angels are holding back they are letting
them loose
how would you describe that
scientifically
climate change thank you we got to the
same point
when he was suffered to afflict job how
quickly flocks and hurts and servants
and houses and children were Swept Away
one trouble succeeding another as in a
moment how would the news describe that
climate change
it's the main broadcaster of this ladau
to Sea so the Pope
Martin this is like a broken record
it is God that Shields his creatures
Hedges them in from the power of the
Destroyer but the Christian world has
shown contempt for the law of Jehovah
and the Lord will do just what he has
declared that he would he will withdraw
his blessing from the earth and remove
his protecting care from those who are
rebelling against his law
and teaching and forcing others to do
the same
Satan has control of all whom God does
not especially God
it's powerful huh yes
he will favor and prosper some in order
to further his own designs and he will
bring trouble upon others
and Lead men to believe that it is God
who is afflicting them is he very
successful in that definitely how many
people blame God for all of this it's
all God's fault how many rock stars
that have achieved great Fame
have died miserable deaths from drug
overdoses or suicides or whatever many
many and then you can also include
actors
all right actors so he uses them until
he's finished with them then he discards
them like
well
like garbage yeah
that's what he does well that's how he
operates so
blessed is he
who hides under the shadow of God's Wing
amen so what all of this means don't
blame God
yes he has said the boundaries but we
know
that Satan is also in this world now can
it happen that in one of these temples
tempests one of God's children or modern
one of God's children can be swept away
in the process yes okay that is
calamitous
that is heartbreaking
but in the light of Eternity
it fades into insignificance because
they will be saved for all eternity
whereas the wicked will not be saved for
all eternity
so even if you succumb in a tempest if
you are under the sadder of his wing
it is temporary
short while
all right that brings us to the next
question why is Moses raised before
Jesus this crucifixion
when his son has not yet been atoned for
by Jesus's sacrifice
that's a very good question it's a it's
actually
brilliant
because uh the Bible has some very
interesting things to say about that
Moses was raised
from the dead and there was an argument
over his body because Satan claimed him
because after all Moses had missed had
done some transgressions right yeah
so the devil climbed them
and the Lord rebuked him
and the rest is history
but now if you go to the Book of Romans
it's very interesting Romans chapter 5
onwards
wherefore as by one man's sin entered
into the world and death by sin
so death passed upon all men for all
have sinned does that include Moses
differently
for until the law sin was in the world
but sin is not imputed when there is no
law
obviously if there is no law there's no
transgression Paul puts it that way in
another place
so when Adam and Eve transgressed was
there a law they had to be otherwise
there couldn't have been a transgression
so people that say there was no law must
be confused because they transgressed
then there must have been a law that
they transgress right okay
and uh which one did they transgress
where did it start it started the same
place where Satan started he coveted the
position of Christ right he was envious
Thou shalt not covet
coveted the spiritual
knowledge that you would obtain
supposedly from imbibing in the tree
of the fruit of the knowledge of Good
and Evil so she broke the tenth
commandment if you break one you break
them oh because it's progression yeah
okay
she actually also broke the first one
of course because she put herself in
place of God because she wanted to be
like God yes and she believed the
usurper more than she believed God so
she had another God beside him
nevertheless death ran from Adam to
Moses
isn't that interesting
even over them that had not sinned after
the similitude of Adam's transgression
which is the figure of him that was to
come
all right so death reigned from Adam to
Moses
and there it was for the first time
demonstrated that death should have no
hold
all right we can actually go back
further we can go back to you know yeah
but Enoch never died yes
he was translated without seeing death
he was the guarantor to the
anti-diluvian world that if you obeyed
God
that you would have eternal life
now when it came to death that rained
until
Moses
in other words there was no resurrection
of anybody that had died until Moses he
was the first one and as this person
rightly said
his sin had not yet been atoned for
so what what happened here well he was a
post-dated check yeah
he was a guarantor
that Christ would redeem him
so he is the Gathering tour to those
that die that there will be a
resurrection
and in the
post-deluvian world
we have Elijah who also was translated
without seeing death so the
anti-deluvian world
had a guarantee in the form of Inno
that you would go to heaven
and live eternally
the post-deluvian world had two
guarantors
one that if you saw death you would be
resurrected Moses
and one that if you didn't see death
depicting those that would be there just
before the coming of Christ
and you were in Christ you would be
translated
which three appeared on the Mount of
transfiguration there's three
okay so the one stood for the law the
other one stood for the prophets and the
other one was Jesus Christ
so you had the law and the testimony and
Jesus Christ
that's what it takes to get to heaven
you need the law you need the testimony
and you need Jesus that's it
it's beautiful all right so it was a
guarantor
now what would have happened had Jesus
failed
then Moses would have fell out of Heaven
back into the grave then he would have
been dead
eternally
uh it's a great risk right
and the the devil was Furious he must
have been Furious when Moses was raised
because
with what right are you doing this this
is my legitimate
prize yes this is mine all right
let's have a look at confrontation page
26 Enoch and Elijah are the correct
representatives of what the race might
be through faith in our Lord Jesus
Christ
Satan was greatly disturbed because
these Noble holy men were untainted
amidst the moral pollution surrounding
them
perfecting righteous characters and
accounted worthy for translation to
heaven
as they had stood forth in the moral
power in Noble uprightness overcoming
Satan's Temptations He could not bring
them under the Dominion of death
a triumphed that he had power to
overcome Moses with his Temptations and
that he could Mar the illustrious
character
and lead him to the sin of taking to
himself Glory before the people which
belonged to God
Christ resurrected Moses and took him to
heaven this enraged Satan and he accused
the Son of God of invading his Dominion
by robbing the grave of his lawful prey
Jude says of the resurrection of Moses
Yet Michael the Archangel when
contending with the Devil he disputed
about the body of Moses does not bring
against him a railing accusation but
said the Lord rebuked thee
when Satan succeeds in tempting men whom
God has especially honored to commit
Grievous sin he triumphs
for his gained to himself a great
Victory and has done harm to the kingdom
of Christ
Martin
does he still do that today no
daily on a daily basis
how careful must we be that we walk
circumspectly
that's why we need to in the morning
start your day with Jesus
kill the old man
and right through the day up until the
evening if you read the Bible some of
these people made a point of preaching
not or praying not just three times a
day but seven times a day
how many
Bright Stars
have gone out in the world how many
evangelists
have fallen prey
to Satan's devices both within the
church and in other denominations
it is a sad fact that if you are in the
business
of evangelism
then you are a special Target yeah
so Martin we need to pray
more
and more that God will preserve us from
this Wily foe because he has many traps
not just one no the spirit of Prophecy
also says when he sees that he's losing
somebody to to God
he Gathers he's ain't his fallen angels
to especially attend to that person
now imagine there are a number of uh
quotes in the spirit of prophecy about
this event and each one gives it a
slightly different twist yeah
some some
spiritual application that always comes
through out of this so let's have a look
at this
Moses passed under the Dominion of death
but he was not to remain in the Tomb
Christ himself called him forth to life
now that's obvious because he's the
author of life and he says that they
will come when all who are in the grave
will hear the voice of the Son of God
and will come forth some to life
Everlasting and others to destruction
right
so Satan the tempted claimed the body of
Moses because of his sin but Christ the
Savior brought him forth from the grave
quoting Jude 9 Moses upon the Mount of
transfiguration
was a witness to Christ's victory over
sin and death
he represented those who shall come
forth from the grave at the resurrection
of the just
Elijah who had been translated to heaven
without seeing death represented those
who will be living upon the Earth at
Christ's Second Coming
and who will be changed in a moment in
the twinkling of an eye at the last
Trump
when this Mortal must put on immortality
and this corruptable must put on
incorruption one Corinthians 15 51-53
Jesus was clothed with the light of
Heaven as he will appear when he shall
come the second time without sin unto
salvation
for he will come in the glory of his
father with his Holy Angels quoting
Hebrews and Mark
the savior's promise to the disciples
was now fulfilled upon the mount the
future Kingdom of Glory was represented
in miniature Christ the King Moses a
representative of the Risen Saints and
the lighter of the translated ones and
as we said he also is the one that gave
the law so he represents the Law and
Elijah the prophet represents the
testimony
it's a it's a gospel in miniature it's a
very beautiful depiction and what's sad
just to bring it also in
Jesus makes it so plain he even made
this plane to his disciples and they
still missed it they still misunder do
they still misunderstand it today that's
what I want to say
we're still missing it
we still allow that Satan blinds us to
see the simple things that Jesus has
Jesus said to his disciples some of you
will witness this some of you here will
witness this that's it and they say but
you know it never happened because they
missed this amen that's exactly what
happens today people say oh but so the
Bible is actually there's a problem yes
and they did it with the spirit of
Prophecy as well exactly now you must
also remember that some prophecy is
conditional none of you will be
destroyed was it destroyed no
because they repented they repented
right
so could there have been translated
when the Lord came was it possible what
about 1888 was it possible yes did it
happen no no because it's conditional
right things not done but here in actual
fact it was not conditional it was a
statement that some would see the
kingdom and they did they saw it in
miniature exactly they saw Christ the
King and they saw the representative of
the resurrected and the representative
of the translated and the law and the
testimony and the King of Kings all of
them together that's the kingdom in
miniature so they saw the kingdom they
saw it I saw it
Jesus had told his disciples that there
were some standing with him who should
not taste of death till they should see
the kingdom of God come with power now
we've already discussed that let's just
give a quote to verify it right
at the Transfiguration This Promise was
fulfilled
the continents of Jesus was there
changed and shunned like the sun these
Raymond was white and glistening Moses
was present to represent those who will
be raised from the dead at the second
appearing of Jesus and Elijah who was
translated without seeing death
represented those who will be changed to
immortality at Christ's second coming
and will be translated to heaven without
seeing death the disciples beheld with
astonishment and fear the excellent
Majesty of Jesus and the cloud that
overshadowed them and heard the voice of
God in terrible majesties saying this is
my beloved Son
hear him
now it's interesting when God speaks he
uses this term
this is my beloved Son
here it says hear him
and another place it says in whom I am
well pleased so this is interesting
Martin when this voice speaks from
heaven
it is to confirm the position of the sun
how can we deny the son If you deny the
son you deny the father and it's so
beautiful because it also says that the
disciples
saw the foreshadowing of Heaven yes
where God the father is and God the son
is yes and where all of this will be and
who is by Jesus's side there the law and
the testimony the law and the testimony
in other words all
that keep the law in the testimony to
the law and the testimony if they speak
not according to this word there's no
light in them
okay here's another question before the
creation of the Angels
God was already that means his Ten
Commandments were also valid before the
creation of beings
if ancients are sexless why was the
seventh commandment valid from the
beginning did it apply in God's
foreknowledge because he knew that he
would create man
which of the Ten Commandments did
Lucifer Satan break
now Martin we've actually answered that
one previously but we'll look at it
again Matthew 22 30 says for in the
resurrection they neither marry nor are
given in marriage but are as the angels
of God in heaven
there's a statement in the spirit of
Prophecy
that the law when it was codified for
Humanity was codified to meet him in the
condition that he was in the principles
of the law
had always existed but the codification
was to meet man where he was
so in other words when it talks about
adultery can you commit spiritual
adultery definitely
so it doesn't have to be physical
adultery right and actually Jesus made
that very clear
yes when he said even if you look at the
woman lustfully yes all right but even
if there wasn't lust I still had
spiritual adultery yes did Satan break
the seventh commandment yeah
wasn't he supposed to be married to
Christ that's it and was he going to
exalt himself and divorce himself from
that situation he committed adultery
yeah
not in a sexual sense but in a spiritual
sense
so before the creation of the Angels God
was already
that means his Ten Commandments were
also valid before the creation of beings
because the Ten Commandments represent
his character
so they were embodied in Christ
and so we have to keep these
Commandments did it apply in God's
knowledge for knowledge because he knew
that he would create man
that too
but it was already there so the
principles never change the principles
never changed the the idea is fixed but
it was codified and written for fallen
Humanity so that they could without a
doubt understand what it was about
so in in the new world the situation
will be different it has not been
revealed exactly what it is like so
let's not go beyond what it is written
except to say
that whatever it will be it will be
better and Superior to what it is now
true and like you've mentioned on that
other episode that we had about the
Lucifer breaking these he broke every
single one all ten all ten not only one
and like we've mentioned before you
break one you break all he actually did
break all tear broke all ten because he
started off with coveting
and in the process of coveting he breaks
the first and the last commandment right
in our first statement I think didn't we
get that from when one of the reasons he
fell was because it started off with
Envy jealousy yes so that's and where
does it lead to
it leads to all the others spiritual
adultery
lying did it lead to murder yes didn't
he murder the Son of God yes didn't he
incite to murder so if it was in his
heart to murder then he murdered right
well didn't he incite Abel to murder yes
did he dishonor his father
definitely so did he break the fifth
commandment
did he break the Sabbath yes yes because
he assumed the authority that belonged
to God that's breaking the Sabbath
irrespective of whether it was
that day or not as soon as he took the
authority he broke the fourth
Commandment
did he break the third commandment yes
yes all his actions break the third
commandment every single one did he
raise himself as an idol and therefore
break the second commandment
and did he have other gods yeah besides
himself himself so he broke them all 10.
so he was a liar from the beginning
and here's a question that we get quite
often I am a woman
I wanted to ask how to apply First
Timothy 2 verse 12.
do you see sister white as having
authority of a man or is she simply seen
as a messenger how do we understand
Deborah the judge in the light of these
words
that the Apostle wrote to Timothy I'm
reading the Bible
live on Facebook video and occasionally
making comments and teaching under those
circumstances
and let's let's read what the quote is
but which becometh woman professing
godliness with good works let the woman
learn in Silence with all subjection but
I suffer not a woman to teach nor to
usurp authority over the man but to be
in silence
pardon
if I maybe tongue-in-cheek has Humanity
ever succeeded in that
trouble I'm gonna be in trouble man I
don't think anybody has ever succeeded
in that one
let's try and unpack this one there are
many statements
that seem on the face of it to be
confusing
if your faith is weak you will eat only
vegetables
[Laughter]
very weak Faith here very weak you'll be
totally plant-based modern so that means
that you and I are in big trouble yeah
we have a very weak faith
how do you how do you look at all of
this put it in context yeah an idol is
nothing because an idol doesn't really
exist right
so if an idol doesn't exist in your
perspective then idolatry is not a
problem right no
so food sacrifice to Idols if your faith
is weak
then you will not eat anything
that has been contaminated in this way
or dedicated to another deity
well that excludes today most of what's
in the supermarket
because it has certain little stamps on
it
yeah so you'll have to become like
Nebuchadnezzar and eat grasses something
like that so we have all of these
strange statements in in the Bible
all right let's ask the question did
Deborah have authority yes yes she was a
prophetess so she had unquestionable
Authority
did Hulda have authority
unquestionable authority
what about Spirit of Prophecy which
you've had uh would Ellen might have had
Authority if Visions were directly from
God definitely has to be has to be
authoritative right although some claim
she didn't have the same Authority but
they had the same inspiration which is
secular reasoning of the highest order
okay so how do you deal with this and
why should the women be silent you must
look at the historic context we must
look at what the situation was because
Paul took the gospel to the Heathen yes
now in Heathen Temple services
the central issue was of a sexual nature
it was a sex cult yeah you can just go
to some of the modern temples
and have a look
at what the depictions are and the
murals are and what some of the Hidden
symbology is it is purely sexual yeah
yeah it has hidden meanings of male and
female anatomy And if you go to some of
the Eastern temples today
and you look on the walls you will see
the most gross acts being depicted this
is the kind of worship that you had and
you had Temple prostitution yeah
and it was customary to take part in
Temple prostitution you were actually
doing the Heathen deities as service by
partaking of it do we have this kind of
orgy going on in today's world as well
definitely it even infiltrates
Christian world let's not let's not go
there because it's too gross to even
talk about so that is the situation and
in these Heathen environments the women
played a very prominent role in teaching
okay now if you take uh the situation
today
you also have the women playing
prominent roles let's say in Catholicism
the nuns are the ones that do the
teaching in the schools and all the
things that pertain to it is there
anything wrong with a woman teaching no
was Deborah a teacher of the law
definitely yes holder a teacher were the
daughters of Philip who were they
prophets yes prophetesses yes
so obviously
uh
the problem doesn't lie with Godly women
no and it also not with the teaching
right
obviously what is being told what is
being taught and how it is being taught
now when you take these hidden uh
priestesses
they were saving
they saved their heads they looked
somewhat like you Martin they do and if
you would excuse me
and they they so often wore a tablet to
close it then or for a veil or something
like that but they were saving do we
have religious systems in the world
where they are shaven yes conjured yes
even in so-called Christian
denominations correct right and in in
other religious systems it is customary
to this day that's it so I do not allow
a woman
to save her head because her hair is a
glory
so he's talking about all of these
heathen
practices
that now had to be excluded from the
church exactly otherwise you would have
had chaos yeah yeah so if a whole
Heathen environment comes into the
church and they bring that whole ritual
with them Paul says whoa no it's not
going to happen here it's not going to
be like this
grow your hair number one yeah this is
not our practice in the church
and please keep quiet until you know
exactly what is going on
and don't come and bring the Heathen
practices into the church the same with
with eating and food and diet if your
faith is weak you will eat only
vegetables because you will be afraid
that the animals will have been
sacrificed to Idols if you go to a
Marketplace they will all sacrificed to
idols
today we have very similar situations
so if your faith is weak you won't touch
it but if you know an idol is nothing
and your faith is strong
then you can partake of everything today
we know of course
that a healthful diet is a plant-based
diet so it has nothing to do with health
issues it had to do with religious
rituals that's it now if my faith is
strong Martin
and there's a sign on let's say the
condiment
that it has been dedicated to another
deity
if my faith is weak I'll throw it away
if my faith is strong I will say you
know what
I don't care because that one doesn't
even exist so this is as far as I'm
concerned a condiment
and I'm going to put it on my food and
then I'm going to ask God to bless my
food and I will consume it because my
faith is strong so all of those
statements in the writings of Paul can
be very confusing if you take them out
of the historic context and the other
problem is you can sometimes exactly
what you've just explained about the
conduit take it to the far extreme again
and forbid everyone else or say that
everything is clean and I can eat as
much as I want and do what I want with
it that's the other thing you have to
keep the balance and go to the whole
biblical picture correct so I hope this
lady will continue teaching if she is
teaching the law and the testimony then
she's doing a great job but then isn't
there also some restrictions or
limitations on this all right portion of
work okay now that is a bone of
contention are you talking about
ordination and things like that Martin
yes okay
uh let's put it this way
does the Bible have a hierarchy yes it
does definitely all right it has a
hierarchy
and the hierarchy is the hierarchy put
in place in order to dominate and be
coercive no
no right not at all no husband love your
wives love is not self-seeking love is
all of these wonderful things right
uh but there's a hierarchy
now God put a hierarchy in place because
he wants to be vindictive right no no
because
that's the hierarchy that he put in
place and it is if anything protective
that he will always do something to
protect you and everybody around you all
right
and there are certain things which a
woman can do
which a man cannot do
let's put it this way it probably can do
it but not to the same extent that a
woman would be able to do it and vice
versa
so in other words you have certain
responsibilities in the creation
and if you Embrace that responsibility
you will be very happy
if you go beyond that responsibility or
seek another one then you could be very
unhappy and you could have situations
that God foresaw
would not be conducive to your state of
mind or your health
so we are supposed to be a team the man
and the woman and the man has certain
roles and the woman has certain roles
and the two are supposed to augment each
other
and become one
and respect each other
in in those respective roles
like for example the woman is the queen
of the house
take your fingers off it's not your
domain you close the door when she tells
you to anyway I think we said enough I
think Martin let
let's leave it at that
and God has hierarchy that's it and
Mankind is bent on turning the hierarchy
upside down and in his church the
highest Authority if they have sat and
made a vote on this I think we should
keep to it
well Martin that is your opinion and I'm
sure that many will differ from that
opinion but that is their problem right
okay so let's leave it at that let's not
uh belabor the point
fact is God has put a certain structure
in place
and as long as time will last there will
be those that will want to turn it
upside down whether it is on the on the
level of human positions
or whether it is on the level of the
environment is going to turn it upside
down definitely okay
all right let's go for a final one in
episode 64
you mentioned that the last plagues will
fall in separate areas of the world and
not all at once on the whole world or
all Humanity will be destroyed can you
tell me where you get this from
Martin why don't we read a few quotes
from The Spirit of Prophecy yes
the plagues upon Egypt when God was
about to deliver Israel were similar in
character to those more terrible and
extensive judgments which are to fall
upon the world just before the final
Deliverance of God's people
says the Revelator in describing these
terrific scourges
they fellow noisome and Grievous sore
upon men which had the mark of the beast
and upon them which worshiped His image
the sea became as blood and of dead men
and every living Soul died in the sea
and the rivers and the fountains of
waters became
blood
terrible as these afflictions are God's
justice stands fully Vindicated the
angel of God declares Thou Art righteous
O Lord because thou has judged us
for they have shed the blood of the
Saints and Prophets and those given them
blood to drink for they are worthy
by condemning the people of God to death
they have as truly incurred the guilt of
their blood as if they had been shed by
their hands in like manner Christ
declares the Jews of his time guilty of
the blood of the holy men which had been
shed since the days of Abel for they
possessed the same spirit and were
seeking to do the same work with these
murderers of the prophets
in the plague that follows power is
given to the Sun to Scorch men with fire
and men were scorched with great Heat
the prophets thus described the
condition of the Earth at this fearful
time the land mourneth because the
Harvest of the field is perished all the
trees of the field are withered because
Joy is withered away from the sons of
men the seed is rotten under their clots
the gardeners are laid desolate how do
the beasts groan the herds of cantaloupe
perplexed because they have no posture
the rivers of water are dried up and the
fire has devoured the pastures of the
wilderness
the songs of the temple shall be howling
in that day says the Lord God there
shall be many dead bodies in every place
they shall cast them forth with silence
quoting Joel and Amos
and then this statement these plagues
are not Universal or the inhabitants of
the Earth would be holy cut off I think
that should answer that question right
yet they will be the most awful scourges
that ever have been known to Mortals all
the judgments upon men prior to the
close of prepassion have been mingled
with Mercy
the pleading blood of Christ has
shielded The Sinner from receiving the
full measure of his guilt but in the
final judgment wrath is poured out
unmixed with Mercy
I can imagine that God being a just God
that those that had great light but
refused it
will suffer more than those who never
had light
right yes
but transgression remains transgression
because the conscience tells you when
something is wrong
the wages of sin still stays deaf
correct
so the plagues are not Universal but
eventually everybody will have
been subjected to them
in that day multitudes will desire the
shelter of God's mercy which they have
so long despised
behold the days come says the Lord God
that I will send a famine in the land
not a famine of bread nor thirst for
water but of hearing the words of the
Lord
and they shall Wander from sea to Sea
and from North even to the east they
shall run to and fro to seek the word of
the Lord and shall not find it
they could have found it yeah but they
refused it right
the people of God will not be free from
suffering
but while persecuted and distressed
while they endure privation and suffer
for want of food they will not be left
to perish
that God who cared for Elijah will not
pass by one of his self-sacrificing
children
your numbers the hairs of the head will
care for them in the time of famine they
shall be satisfied
while the wicked are dying from hunger
and pestilence angels will shield the
righteous and Supply their wants
to him that walketh righteously is the
promised bread shall be given him his
Waters shall be sure
when the poorer need his seek water and
there is none and their tongue faileth
for thirst I the Lord will hear them I
the god of Israel will not forsake them
quoting Isaiah so Martin there's a lot
of Hope
even in this great Calamity you see that
and I think that's important for people
to realize because a lot of people just
hear of the seven lost plagues and they
are so fearful
forgetting that God has a promise for
those that are faithful correct
so I hope that these questions have been
addressed
and that we have encouraged people
not to fear
it will be a bad time the time of
trouble that is upon us
but we've had all of these promises
promise of a resurrection a promise of a
translation a promise that your bread
and water will be sure there will be
Affliction God will take care of it I
mean that's all that we can aspire to
you mentioned earlier all of this is a
small Speck in eternity yes and heaven
will be cheap enough amen let's pray
Heavenly Father
we thank you for your word because your
word does not only give warning
but it also gives encouragement and we
thank you for this in Jesus name amen
amen
[Music]
foreign